pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis tel aviv en israël avec paula
stayers journaliste d'arte et
internationales ont soir paul à le
comité consultatif ont bien le dire qui
recommande une quatrième dose de vaccin
tous les adultes quelles sont les
réactions sur place a en france on le
sait il ya quelques récalcitrants qui
n'apprécierait pas effectivement eu une
quatrième dose comment on réagit dans
l'état hébreu
plus d'un demi million de personnes sont
contaminées par l'accident
non il ya six exactement à 590 personnes
hier 80 mille nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés
c'est la deuxième journée consécutive où
ont été enregistrés plus de 80 mille
nouveaux cas
mais le ministre de la santé a déclaré
qu'une pluie 80 doses
pourraient être considérés pour les
personnes âgées et avait été décidée
pour les personnes âgées et les
personnes vulnérables
il ne s'agissait pas à l'époque d'une
décision facile et il n'envisage pas de
l'étendre à toute la population
pour le moment il s'agit simplement des
personnes de plus de 60 ans et des
personnes vulnérables
pour résumer confirmé
consultatif est composée de 50 membres
une majorité de ses membres a voté en
faveur de l'intérim deux d'entre eux ont
dit que cette quatrième doses devraient
être destinés aux personnes de plus de
40 ce pan et 8 personnes on dit que cela
devait être uniquement destiné aux
personnes à risque alors qu'adriano
défenseur ou de modern a augmenté le
niveau d'anticorps chez les personnes
vaccinées mais le sérum et est moins
efficace un contre omikron selon un
communiqué de presse publié hier par un
hôpital près de tel aviv ce n'est pas un
peintre contresens
même si vous l'avez préciser ces
réserves est une catégorie de personnes
enfin si ce n'est pas efficace contre le
varié en dominant
d'après le professeur qui a mené l'étude
a pris leur essor qui a mené l'étude ce
n'est sans doute pas une bonne idée
d'injecter une quatrième dose à la
population générale ce qui correspond à
sec a déclaré le ministre de la santé
mais pour les personnes qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables
alors cette quatrième dose est une bonne
idée dans le même temps elle a expliqué
que la campagne actuelle
qui vise les personnes de plus de 60 ans
et les personnes vulnérables devraient
être amendé afin d'ouvrir cette
vaccination aux personnes
âgées en général
elle a également déclaré que les jeunes
ne sont pas les plus exposés ne sont pas
les plus malades de la coved elle ne
pense donc pas qu'une quatrième dose est
nécessaire ou devrait être ouverte à la
jeunesse elle a déclaré que ce serait un
record le comité consultatif cependant a
décidé d'encourager cette quatrième dose
d'après un les chiffres qui montrent pas
que ceux qui ont reçu une quatrième dose
et qui ont plus de 60 ans elles sont
trois fois plus protégés face à des
formes graves de la maladie que des
personnes qui la neige reçue ce que
trois
clips en israël mais jane reçoivent
trois doses
d'après les experts cela devrait suffire
mais que si une parcelle de moins de 60
ans décide de prendre une troisième dose
alors cela ne leur nuira pas cela ne
peut que renforcer leur protection merci
beaucoup pour la salière journalistes rt
internationale nous avoir exposé la
situation donc dans l'état libre merci à
vous